No why can you support a school choice
and why can you talk about your schools
why do you talk about a voucher system
as libertarians been talking about for a
long time we've been saying this and you
say that school choice is racist you are
bought and paid for by them you just
made a case for school choice while
saying that you hate school choice
question of the day let me ask this do
you think too much attention is actually
being given to Alexandria Nina Pinta
Santa Maria Cortez or is it pretty clear
that the left is headed in a specific
direction here namely socialism so
leaders like Cortez need to be addressed
and their views need to be dissected
there are a lot of people said why are
you giving this person all this with all
of this attention
I understand I understand that she's
just one person but I also understand
that there are a lot of people who see
her as a symbol for the Democratic Party
and certainly want the party to go in
that direction so I'm curious to hear
what you guys think it could be yes to
both by the way I think it's possible
I'll make that point later it's possible
so I recently tweeted Dez asking for
examine sponsor asking for examples of
systemic discrimination in the United
States today she responded with the
following I think we have her tweets
right here she responded in a K through
12 education mass incarceration banks
targeting black Americans before the
housing crisis she's been cordially
invited to appear on the show by the way
haven't heard back as far as I know
here's something important as well she's
never appeared on a show with an
opposing viewpoint no ever I can't find
it I've never found it we've been doing
research all morning please tweet me
leave a comment if there's a video of
her going on a conservative show a show
that would hold her feet to the fire or
there'd be any kind of debate please let
me know as far as I understand she
exclusively preaches to the converted so
we're forced to go through a tweet
because she wouldn't appear in the show
and by the way I was stunned that these
were the examples she chose because
these are examples that a first-year
short of diversity studies to gender
studies take your pick I don't have
diversity studies or so news to her it's
a lay up it's like a first semester
philosophy college student would pick
these and they are some of the most
easily debunked
so as somebody else do as we go through
these here's something to keep in mind
of course you've all heard correlation
does not equal causation but more
importantly here disparity doesn't equal
discrimination we'll come back to that
later so let's go through point 1 school
funding okay right away off the top
schools aren't segregated there are no
white school
and black schools by law so it can't be
about race when we're talking about
systemic discrimination so let's take a
look at what could actually be causing
the funding disparity first of all if
you actually bother to read the wopo
article yeah that she is referencing she
doesn't actually put it in the tweet no
sense look it up get the person knock on
your door a--they encyclopedia
it's just splurged you'll find it it's
real I'm gonna go out so you find the
disparity by the way the original effort
has nothing to do with race and it has
nothing to do with the system it's
really based on how money is raised from
property taxes
yeah and they did that because they
wanted more local control surprisingly I
wanted to make sure if they sold a bond
that they that you had a really high bar
to clear so that the local residents
said yes to that bond right something
that she would probably champion by the
way the system in question that specific
article the state budget actually gave
more to non-white schools just to keep
in mind that talk word but she does help
she doesn't make a point here and this
is where I agree with Cortez um it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense that
people should be forced to attend a
specific school just because they live
in a crappy district she didn't
mentioned this by the way on an
interview where she talked about needing
to change the way when she wasn't trying
to hockey skate with its racism when she
was talking about in an interview the
way school funding needs to change
here's what she said one of the things
that we really need to reassess when we
talk about economic inequality and
reducing economic inequality is our
basic system of funding schools the
basic idea that the immediate property
taxes of a certain zip code funds that
local public schools because then what
it does it creates this mad - I think by
kind of re-examining how we even gauge
these issues is one of the basic things
that we take for granted but it could
actually be one of the strongest keys
and unlocking the opportunities of
children in the United States school
choice school why can't you support a
school choice and why can you talk about
charter schools why do you talk about a
voucher system as libertarians been
talking about for a long time we've been
saying this and you say that school
choice is racist why because you have to
appease the big unions who give far
more than Big Oil of the Koch brothers a
Rupert Murdoch big unions particularly
if you look at public sector unions and
public education unions you are bought
and paid for by them you just made a
case for school choice while saying that
you hate school choice even if you agree
with the premise here when you talk
about schooling you have you have to
follow the logic trail or you have to
follow their logic trail that more money
would equal better success in school
that's not true and higher per spending
pupil does not equate to greater success
if there is now that's a great example
where there isn't even a correlation you
couldn't say that correlation equals
causation but there are schools that
have more funding like in Detroit than
the national average and I do horribly
and then there are schools you say have
far less funding that do much better for
example there's some schools in certain
districts of New York where they
couldn't understand they're gonna hold a
second they have bigger classroom sizes
they don't have the same amount of
spending per pupil and they were doing
far better because of better teachers
and incentives I mean their most
students she probably should have just
stayed away from this public public
education has been a train wreck for a
very very very long time and this
distracts from a real issue like she'd
it's like she just tried to pick out
like three basic things and say well
that'll work yeah there's an article
that I can educate some and it's all
about money check mate
even though we de proven that it's not
tweet this tweet speaks for itself and I
think the conversation needs no further
discussion point by the way massive
she's points to mass incarceration which
doesn't really give us a whole lot to go
on but she's trying to further this idea
that the criminal justice system
unfairly targets blacks through drug
policies right prosecute them unfairly
it's it's a common talking point amongst
the left here here's just a video that's
an example drug laws were made in
explicitly racist circumstances for
explicitly racist reasons for example
the first anti cocaine laws were made
because cocaine supposedly made black
men impervious to bullets and prone to
getting involved with white women first
off that's not true
second I think she's trying to imply
here that people on crack or people on
meth aren't more likely to commit
violent crimes there are some Japanese
kamikaze pilots who'd like to speak with
you also by the way the whitest people
on us
the Nazis like it is absolutely true
that people who do hardcore drugs
particularly a stimulus like crack
cocaine and methamphetamine commit more
crimes I don't know why they're like if
it's racism no no they do those drugs
that's wise to go to the argument at
large because she just said
incarceration yes black people make up a
disproportionate percentage of the
prison population but they also commit a
disproportionate percentage of the
crimes they commit murder for example at
more than double the rate of white
Americans okay yeah and again if you
look more closely you can find reasons
for the disparity in the drug crime
specifically that they mentioned that
don't equal discrimination yes okay
here's a good example 81% of crack
cocaine defendants are black but only 2%
of meth defendants are black yeah with
54% of them being white that means that
Matt realiza laws target whites 27 times
more than blacks see we can play that
game to met targets targets whites I bet
if you were to include people have sex
with their sister it's probably 84 times
more than blacks by the way economists
as heroin is the wonder drug that bridge
is the racial divide good good we'll be
in trouble so our meth Hua's are the
anti white anymore than crack laws or
anti but different demographics commit
different types of crime that's why
there's a disparity there is a through
line through all these disparities for
example not doing well in school or
ending up in prison see if you can guess
before that they'll hit the notification
bail since subscriptions don't mean
anything anymore and you actually do a
day sadducees you jus you breasts all
are on the brain the Jew the Jew they
might trick you notification subscribe
on iTunes all right let's continue like
this is going well so the point the
third point she makes is that banks are
targeting minorities right thanks cortez
claims that targeted black americans i
wouldn't use the word targeting but okay
let's go with your premise there's there
is validity miss Cortez to your claim
why because of your party here's
qualifing agents who say well there are
no vacancies right now
that you just didn't qualify for the
mortgage because your financial credit
history wasn't good enough but some
valid reason last year the Federal
Reserve Board found african-americans
have denied credit for homes at twice
the rate white Americans are what twice
the rate that's almost two times more
twice three 27 times written prosecution
of white Americans for math anyone is
eighty something times their prosecution
of black Americans for for crack cocaine
20 straight white let's just use numbers
twice the right okay what was the credit
score what was the money down what was
the income we can play that game cuz we
just want to say that white people got
Bank home loans at twice the rate
therefore racism that's not how you look
into statistics your party targeted
banks told them they had to lend them
more people of color regardless of
income ability money down or credit
score Cuomo himself established the
affordable housing goals which gave
Fannie Mae Freddie Mac annual quotas for
giving low-income mortgages I've never
understood this predatory how could
banks profit from giving loans to people
who couldn't possibly pay them back
why would thanks target them it was like
a shark targeting a fish to throw up
food in its mouth it doesn't make any
sense it was government policies that
targeted low-income individuals and with
fees loans and caused the housing crisis
they required banks to give out loans to
people who couldn't pay them back or
face the consequences a bank is
typically in the business by the way you
know who didn't getting a home the black
doctor just so you know sure Louise is
completely inaccurate do you do you
think ben Carson would walk into a bank
in the response be well everything here
checks out but we don't take kindly to
your killers around here but it's money
in the bank
I mean basically paying for a bank a
bank loan he walks in he's got a wife
and kids he's got a job he's got a
perfect credit score he's got all the
money down and they're like well I would
give it to you if you were a Negro
that's all
milk's in the real world no especially
with are there some racists by the way
of course there are but to try and act
like the housing crisis was caused by
banks targeting black people to make
sure that they take the money they could
never pay back it just shows a lack of
any threat listen I'm not saying that
there aren't examples of individual
racism of course but I have asked for
examples of discrimination what she gave
me and you by proxy here's something
else too people say why do you focus on
her so much she's an elected official
yeah she is paid by our tax dollars it
is it's not punching up looking to gain
ratings her job is to respond turk
constituency that's her job it is
entirely appropriate to respectfully ask
for her to answer these questions she
give examples of discrimination that
were actually just disparity that's all
it was another way there doesn't mean
there aren't any problems with what
she's outlined there there certainly are
examples of discrimination this is
though what she's done is it's a symptom
of a syndrome okay that there is a
problem that only government can fix -
right the racial injustice 'as of the
past there's a common denominator by the
way that I talk to myself would come
back to it that could lead to this
disparity among any race white black
yellow what could plummet ask this what
could possibly be the pop common
denominator okay that could lead to a
disparity in success in school that
would also possibly lead to a disparity
in incarceration rates or saving up
enough money to get a home let me let me
answer that with an antidote anecdote
first followed by some data okay I was
at baby shower this weekend my wife is
out of town so I had to attend and I
brought Betty hoodie so her parents and
their kids and Betty's a puppy and so
we're trying to socialize with as many
dogs and as many kids as possible yeah
she's out there running around playing
there was this boy who was screaming by
the way any time he wanted attention
just scream shove another kids in the
bouncy hop he walked up and punched
Betty in the ribs Oh as hard as he could
just right where the spine meets ribs
just sounded just like that now and then
he walked up and he yanked on her tail
and he looked me Johnny boy was there
looked me in the eyes and started
stepping on her tail after I told him to
stop now oh we gonna die I say this
because if we robbery probably
probably bitten the kiddies older he
doesn't play that right and that's
another problem after like dog know if
you punch a dog in the ribs you're kind
of asking for it but uh the racist would
look at that and say oh black kid but
you know what I saw I saw a kid at that
baby shower with the only mother without
a wedding ring or a father he was the
only kid there without a dad and as far
as I know he doesn't have a dad now I
could give that kid free school for life
I could get him a guaranteed job I could
walk up and hand that mom a million
dollars and it wouldn't make a damn a
difference because he doesn't have a
debt so because he was black know all
kids do poorly without debt they're more
likely to drop out of school to commit
crimes to be violent to have
psychological problems or behavioral
disorders to have marital problems of
their own down the what to make a lower
income across the boards okay
black kids do poorly without a dad white
kids do poorly without a dad but
seventy-three percent of black kids
don't have a debt but because cortez
sees blacks as a voting block she then
interprets all of these disparities as
discrimination but there really is at
least one easily explainable reason for
this or at least one correlation that
makes sense across the board kids who
don't have dads do poorly in life now
the left has been accusing the right of
using this as a cop-out for all these
disparities which clearly are examples
of systemic discrimination and only only
only if you really looked at the
systemic problems of racial and just you
know what here's the truth if you look
at them you examine them just like they
don't exist the largest part of this
solution is right in front of your faces
their faces our faces but the left
couldn't possibly acknowledge it because
that would be dabbling in the realm of
moral absolutism or maybe passing
judgment and we couldn't have the
leaders of the DNC doing that we
couldn't have them saying you know what
let me use my sound judgment here it
seems that there is a strong correlation
here and I do believe there could be
some causation that kids without dad's
don't do well if we're going to try and
socially engineer people why don't we
look at something that is undeniable and
encourage men to be better husbands
fathers dad's in the household you do
that you'd fix a lot you certainly would
fix a lot of problems not all of them
but everybody would have a better head
start at least but we're not supposed to
talk about it the DNC could never do
that Cortez the intellectual heavyweight
for them okay if you like this video you
know you watch videos on YouTube if I
were Jimmy Kimmel if I were Stephen
Colbert or Trevor Noah I would tell you
to subscribe but I have no corporate
overlords who demand that I do this
demeaning promo I do the demeaning promo
because I choose to subscribe or hit the
notification bell because I need you I
need you please do it